par douze fois l'amour vrai les avaient
emporté au sommet fabuleux de la fille
cité de revin dans leur passion
source d'art à leurs
nouvelles
par douze fois l'amour
les
emporter
mais où
13e et
le
malheureusement par la nature eux
fut le travail
claude vega un imitateur
inimitable un être fait de poésie et de
sensibilité qui quel que soit le
personnage choisi a toujours les mots et
les expressions juste regarder n'êtes
vous pas avec louis de funès
maître corbeau sur un arbre perché
tenait en son bec un fromage
maître renard par l'odeur alléché 8,4 à
peu près ce langage
un monsieur du corbeau quand vous êtes
jolie que vous me semblez beau sans
mentir si vous tombez nez niel se
rapporte à votre moule vous êtes le
phénix des hôtes de c'est pourquoi
il a des yeux rieurs et un regard étonné
sur les choses de la vie il a le sens de
l'humour
regardez
la laque ali
ça déboule chez les lavabos
en une nuit
la vie
la locale
sur les tâches ça fait merveille
et
[Musique]
de toutes ces imitations les plus
extraordinaires sont à mon avis elle
d'elvire popesco et de delphine seyrig
regarder
[Musique]
irina en pigeons mon coeur la voilà la
voilà il est tombé sur nos épaules de
femmes tremblante la catastrophe que je
vous doutez début des jours et des jours
il faut partir d'ici l'avis de
l'expulsion il arriver ce matin nous
devons quitter notre chef de type datcha
de kremlin-bicêtre
ilina adam tu l'as dans la splendeur
pathétique de cette belle journée qui va
mourir entends-tu le bruit monstrueux de
marteau piqueur sans âme il a déjà
saccagés 3 gt mais bégonias dans les
jardins et tout ça pour faire pousser
une autoroute nationale à la place
les misérables savent donc pas que ce
toulouse il va passer aussi sur mon
coeur
veut nous chasser de ses terres
chaumières pour reléguer dans une hlm à
clapiers comme centre rationnés ça y est
je les dis mais ce n'est réabonner à ce
n'est rien
ne restons pas prisonnière d'une
mentalité typiquement réactionnaire
comprends moi ici nous vivions trop
celles prises au piège dangereux de
l'individualisme bourgeois
tandis que trente huitième étage dans
notre petit deux pièces mal insonorisés
nous allons avoir enfin un destin
collectif
monia nous allons connaître chaque jour
le cri de l'enfant la gifle du père
excédé les scènes de ménage
bouleversant claude vega y at il un
personnage que vous rêver d'imiter
oui je n'ai pas encore assez rêver parce
que pour moi ce sera un personnage
inconnu et ce serait dans une pièce de
théâtre comprenez
c'est à dire que j'aimerais bien jouer
une pièce de théâtre mais j'ai pas
encore trouvé
quelques propositions mais j'ai pas
trouvé
ce que j'aimerais faire encore régresser
quoi rire quoi dans une pièce de théâtre
évidemment je peux pas jouer burt
lancaster au 10
mai un personnage qui se rapporte à un
petit peu à mon physique quoi mais
j'aimerais bien faire du théâtre
[Musique]